Muhammad I spoke yesterday with Michael
Tenenbom tenenbaum partners and he
talked about how technology is a game
changer because it's sucking huge
amounts of capital away from other
businesses and that this becomes a
cyclical process what asset classes do
you see attracting more money so he's
absolutely right that's something very
exciting going on in the tech space and
that is the ability to disrupt
traditional industries coming from
another world look what uber has done to
urban transportation though we'll look
what Airbnb has done to sheraton star
Ward and Hilton okay they are disrupting
those sectors without building a hotel
building without having taxis that they
own themselves so that this is a very
exciting time for tech because you can
disrupt from another world I don't
believe that that means you're crowding
out other sources of funding there's
lots of capital available for the right
opportunities the problem today is not
the lack of capital the problem is that
economic risk taking in certain areas is
not high enough and therefore they're
not using capital just look at all the
cash is that is that a psychological or
behavioral issue what is that link to
it's linked to various things one is
linked to the uncertainty about the
future people don't have enough clarity
about whether the economy will reach
escape velocity and they're worried
about international demand second it's
linked to uncertainty about policies
corporate reforms and finally you know
this is a special world in which when it
takes all when it comes to certain
technological innovations therefore you
want to keep cash on your balance sheet
to be able to move when that opportunity
arrives and that's why we're seeing
economic risk taking down here while
financial is taking by Marcus has been
up here